we're going to begin with breaking news
overnight a suspect in the killing of a
supporter of a far-right group in
portland over the weekend
is dead today u.s marshals say that
48-year-old michael reinold
pulled a gun on them as members of a
task force tried to arrest him
in lacey washington last night officers
opened fire
weinell had strongly suggested that he
was the one responsible for a crime
in a tv interview he said he felt he had
no choice
his victim aaron j danielson was linked
to an
ultra-conservative group patriot prayer
members of that group say that's why he
was killed late saturday night
lilia luciano is in portland which is
nearing 100 days of protest lilia
how are things there now
good morning to you anthony for months
the area around this federal courthouse
has been ground zero for portland
protesters and look
most protests have been peaceful but now
something changed
a right-wing protester was killed last
weekend
and that resulted in the police shooting
and killing of a left-leaning
suspect and this is all happening as
organizers on both sides
are planning on a big turnaround
throughout the entire
holiday weekend as we mark the hundred
days of protests here
cbs news has learned that michael reinel
seen here
in cell phone video after being shot was
located by the fbi in lacey washington
less than 50 miles southwest of seattle
as marshals
tried to apprehend him law enforcement
officials say rynell pulled a gun
and he was shot and killed by at least
one officer on the scene
rynell was a suspect in saturday night's
shooting death of aaron j
danielson who was part of the right-wing
group patriot prayer
joey gibson the group's founder says
danielson was
targeted they don't know who jay is they
didn't kill him as an individual they
didn't kill him because of something he
did
it felt like the beginning of a war
shortly before his death was reported
rynell appeared on vice news tonight
and said he opposed the right-wing
protest in portland
and was forced to shoot in self-defense
you feel that it was totally justified
totally justified had i not acted i am
confident that my friend and i'm sure i
would have been killed
after the vice interview aired president
trump tweeted
why aren't the portland police arresting
the cold-blooded killer of aaron j
danielson do your job and do it fast
there have been nightly demonstrations
in the city since may
they've been limited to 10 locations in
portland mainly government buildings
we were out here because we were mad we
were out here because of
a built-up frustration of 400 years of
black people being oppressed by a
systematically racist system
alisha atkins has helped organize the
protest in response to the death of
george floyd
the group wants criminal justice reform
and substantial police budget cuts
some have used the protest to incite
violence which adkins
has to cry
[Applause]
do that in the name of black lives
matter you're not for us you're actually
you're fully against us because you're
doing things that we're going to be
fully held accountable for
after rhinel's death was reported the
founder of patriot prayer went on
instagram and claimed
that he believes the suspect is only one
of a dozen people
involved in his friend's killing and is
calling on his followers
to not rest until everybody he believes
was involved
is brought to justice tony
still a lot of questions lilia thank you
very much